when it comes to small screen couples
there are virtually no rules as to who
might hook up with home
remember that time Tony Soprano slept
with his Russian mistresses one-leg
cousin or when the tough interrogator
Sayid and the spoiled rich girl Shannon
became such a surprisingly satisfying
pair unlost anything can and does happen
when it comes to TV romances but that
doesn't mean it's always okay in the
case of these on-screen couples the X
Factor stemmed from their significant
age differences which made them nearly
unwatchable at times Gloria and Jay so
modern family has been credited with
breaking new ground on television the
romance between Gloria and Jay has been
accused of retreating behind familiar
stereotypes ed O'Neill's Jay was an
aging businessman who had a caustic
relationship with his ex and Sofia
Vergara's Gloria was a single mother who
was happy to take on the mantle of
trophy wife for the sake of financial
security 35 years we worked together and
he couldn't wait 10 minutes to run off
with Charo as a joke joke I'm kidding
there's almost three decades of an age
difference between O'Neill and Vergara
and although they have a good time
working together in real life certain
moments of romance between the two can
be a little unsettling to watch and it
makes me uncomfortable the redeeming
factor of their relationship is that the
rest of the family has been allowed to
mock the lopsided couple mercilessly
over the years I know what your things
I've called these you know she's saying
gold yes in Carey and Alexander
Petrovsky the relationship portrayed on
Sex in the City could hardly be
considered traditional remember
Samantha's naked sushi rejection yeah it
was a weird show but in terms of
uncomfortable age gaps
Carrie Bradshaw took the cake with a
strange patriarchal attraction to
Alexander Petrovsky the Russian artist
Bradshaw spent an entire series falling
in and
love with men who are all wrong for her
but Petrovsky was one of the worst he
was emotionally needy and distant at the
same time and undermined her career
achievements for the sake of pumping his
own ego the fact that he treated her
more like a neglected daughter than a
true partner made the age gap that much
more awkward to watch unfold think
you're acting like a child and I think
you're acting like a detective Andy
Sipowicz and Connie McDowell
no matter the scenario watching NYPD
Blue Sipowicz get it on with Connie was
always going to be uncomfortable
beyond the relationships physical
mismatch the psychology behind it was
also questionable McDowell and Sipowicz
bonded over her struggle to reconnect
with the daughter she was forced to give
up as Miguel's maternal yearning
attracted her to Sipowicz a grieving
widower and single dad to a young son
even the showrunners knew it would be
hard for audiences to swallow executive
producer bill Clark told the Los Angeles
Times that making separates and McDowell
hook-up on the show was like walking
onto a minefield it was not the nice
little person Deborah and Lundy the
unusual relationship between Deborah and
Lundy on Dexter was actually pretty well
regarded by fans who at that point in
the series were just ready for Deb to
have any stable relationship yes
Lundy was old enough to be her father
and yes he was sort of a superior
officer but at least he wasn't secretly
gift-wrapping severed body parts and
leaving them all over Miami that we know
of Hannah and Joshua HBO's girls was
brimming with bad relationships
especially for lena Dunham's leading
character Hannah but while most of the
hookups were age-appropriate one episode
portrayed her bizarre and unlikely to
day romance with an older man named dr.
Joshua the jury got together after
Hannah followed him to his house and
they were in full horizontal mambo mode
within minutes with all the deep talk
between the two coming
they split up almost as quickly as they
got together but the idea that a
middle-aged doctor wouldn't hesitate to
bed a twenty-something with no notice
was tired try bed fast Blanche and Dirk
though she was the self-professed man
crazy one out of all the roommates on
the Golden Girls
Blanche only had one romantic encounter
with a notably younger man in one
episode Blanche who has never revealed
her true age was asked to do not buy her
Jazzercise instructor Dirk and of course
the awkward conversation started flowing
not only did he tell her she reminded
him of his mother but Blanche's
descriptions of their torrid affair were
especially unsettling I have decided to
overlook that minor detail and succumb
to the Vesuvius of passion that is about
to erupt from me and back we're going to
get something on us that is as close to
hearing your grandma described having
sex as you'd want to get thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Applause]